Aaron Sampson here with Darin sub
created director of for tonight thanks
for having me by welcome today we're
gonna take a look at some pretty
high-level epic characters we're gonna
try and take a look at some epic forts
we're gonna take a look at cool weapons
and just generally get a good overview
of a fortnight which is out in early
access that's right it's out on pc mac
ps4 and xbox one right now so first
question just sort of high level
fortnight so it's been in development
for a long time you guys are going early
access now and then you guys are looking
to do free to play in about a year what
just kind of tell me about for people
who don't know about fortnight just
about the high level concept of
fortnight yeah for tonight is our
cooperative action builder where players
loot scavenge and ultimately defend
giant forts against hordes of monsters
and they do it all in a procedurally
generated world so that's really
interesting because it's a procedurally
generated world I feel like you know
games like this are all about that loot
chase mm-hmm what is the what's the idea
behind a lot of games in recent times
like post destiny have gone in that
direction of making the loot chase the
primary focus of the game and they've
gotten rid of corner of the the large
open worlds that you used to find in
MMOs
so in terms of fortnight how are you
guys pushing that loot chase without the
large the large zone yeah you know yeah
that's a good question so basically you
know RPGs since the since the beginning
of time have about and have been about
gathering cool powerful loot for for the
players and you know becoming more
powerful and feeling more awesome you
know wall exploring the game world and I
think that's been you know the concept
with everything and then the environment
that you express that in I think is just
ends up becoming secondary yeah the the
a lot of my background is actually in in
online games like that but people ended
up becoming a little
I think sometimes lost in those giant
worlds where they're like hey I'm alone
but there's all the square footage and I
think one of the things we learned early
on was fortnight that we actually had
the world bigger than what they are
today but what players ultimately found
that a little bit overwhelming so we
actually started constraining them but
left all the good RPG we chase in it and
that the elements we had of that before
so yeah it's it's it's definitely the
staple of getting getting awesome stuff
becomes the the focus and the smaller
worlds and with smaller groups actually
makes you feel more like a hero it's
more personally connected as opposed to
I'm one person on a landscape of like
255 like you know we're back in the the
EverQuest days right where there was
hordes of people like beating on one
monster it was you kind of felt a little
lost and less less a rug in the end I
think the new models are where people
are playing in the new games like
destiny or fortnight you know it's a
smaller experience with four people so
you can really feel your impact were
there any changes in the industry while
you guys were in development in this
game that caused you to to change
aspects of the game for example again
like destiny or like Diablo like it
seems like those games have evolved and
learned a lot of tough lessons over time
yeah definitely I mean I think I think
the biggest thing that all the games
sort of in the modern age have sort of
evolved into is the fact that they're
all online and they can be updated and
iterated through with the players to
make the game better and so I think all
those games actually learn in real time
like what you know what is our players
like what are they into and how do we
how do we make that you know how do we
make the best experience for that and it
comes with a lot of power but it's also
interesting too because like it's like a
piece of art because it's never done at
that point right and so players are all
like when's it going to be done well you
know a lot of the a lot of these modern
games are completely iterating over and
over again and they reinvented Diablo 3
with with an expansion it was awesome
right that evolution they wanted to do
it and and I think I think that's that's
developers taking taking advantage of
the platforms they're there on in order
to do that the technology allows us to
do that we don't we're no longer
constrained
you just a singular disc we can we can
update content on the fly we can make
changes to make the game better and more
fun and you know I think that the the
only real hurdle behind that is that it
takes it you you have to be prepared for
the long haul like you know to iterate
through that stuff and you know these
games take commitment it's like you know
as I've said you know we've been we've
been working on this game for a while
and we intend to continue to work on it
but a lot of you know not everybody can
have that luxury
I imagine yeah like I imagine having to
perpetually develop cuts both ways it's
it's really interesting I think we've
had different people in our in our
comments section when we're talking
about games these days they almost
expect an end game and you know we're
laughing a lot of people here at
GameSpot remember a time when endgame
meant you returned the disk to Game Stop
and then bought another game yeah so
like what's it like developing for a
game because you guys have a year-long
plan right now so you have early access
and then your goal is to go free-to-play
in a year in a year's time yeah so what
are like what are the challenges to to
that endless development cycle or that
like an idea that you're always making
endgame contests yeah you're you're
always making new events and new
activities for the players to players to
engage with and I think the cool part
with regards to the content and events
and the things that interest players
aside from the foundation being
everyone's like what's the loot I'm
gonna get for the for the for the
activity you're gonna make me
participate in but I think we get to we
do get to this part is sort of decently
mapped the the mmo's and the online
games of the past have shown us like the
pathway through of like hey players like
to participate in holiday events you
know they want you know husks with
little Santa hats on there on their head
during the holiday season you know they
want to do spooky Halloween events or
they want to do you know let's say
hypothetically we you know we have in an
endless wave mode that comes out and it
runs for a three week cycle and players
see how far they can get during that and
then and then they get a bunch of
rewards for the kind of thing it's like
there's a pretty good road map of the
way that you treat your players with
regards to that once you decide that
this is the type of game you are and so
yeah early on we
we we when we decided to up our scope
we're like we're pretty sure this is
where we're gonna end up so yeah and
here we are
so things yeah things like popular games
like overwatch you're doing now like a
timed exclusive loot and holiday events
and actually quite a few games like I
think Rainbow six siege is is trying to
follow that model titanfall sort of
chasing that model yep yeah I mean you
know I you know I participated in in
lore of the Rings online where you're
like what's the holiday special for the
hobbits and you're running around and
and and trying to engage those players I
think there's been a bunch of game types
that have existed in the space for a
long while I just think everybody else
is like yeah that is pretty fun let's do
more of that and so the industry is as a
whole is doing it kind of feel like if
you play as a hobbit you're only
concerned about how many breakfast
you're oh yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely that's that's definitely
there there there about pies actually
it's how we roll that's how they level
up yep first breakfast second breakfast
other breakfast
speaking of leveling so characters in
this game are there classes but they're
also random so what's your favorite
class what's your personal favorite
class and what what is random within the
character yeah so so ever actually I
think everybody I've talked to you sort
of on videos or whatever always asked me
like hey what's your favorite class and
and and and I realize that everyone's
like it's a cop-out answer but it's
really like picking much which which
child and you're in your family that let
you like best and so I don't I don't
have a particularly favorite I think I
just go through phases like right now
I'm I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to
power up my Ramirez but yesterday I'm
one of another stream I was playing the
Islanders like maybe I should do that so
I don't really I don't really have a
favorite but the way the way the heroes
themselves work all our heroes are cards
basically so they're they're unique
people they have they have a name they
have and they have a specialty and
they're basically part of the class
family so you'll have like the
constructor as an example there's
different specs of them in different
heroes and and we have a hero called
penny she's the she's the big
constructor that everybody sees with the
with the pink hair and the hammer and we
have a card that's tank penny and she's
designed to be a tanky
sort of like melee fighter but
ultimately we have other constructors
that that amplify their base device
which is a one of as a class ability
that basically makes walls regenerate or
deals damage to creatures when they
attack them but those are just different
specs and so those heroes have they
actually they're the heroes themselves
are not randomized they have a spec and
they belong to a family so players are
like okay this is the guy that's about
to base defense and this is a guy this
is the constructor that's about finding
melee and clearing walls so so they're
not the actual properties on the heroes
themselves are not randomized they're
just fixed cards that you can define and
flex hmm so it seems like within those
classes those abilities appeared in
different orders for example the ninjas
ninja stars and Dragons slash might be
first or second yep depending on so you
have to use star levels which is where
you max level of character and then you
starla Ville them yep to get that second
set of abilities yep so those aren't
randomized or they are within no they
are not randomized those abilities that
you're getting are part of a spec that a
designer has looked at and said hey the
car the way these these abilities work
and this order is a is a way that we we
want those we want these to work and
they usually create some synergies with
regards to the to the player so they're
not totally random this allows us to we
actually went through this the you know
iterative development of of picking all
the pieces and then and then true
randomization in the end we have this
hybrid model based on feedback where
it's like yeah this allows us to curate
a good experience for a particular hero
card and ultimately balance it in the
long run it's like is this hero card for
you know effective enough true
randomization or true or or true picking
it generates all kinds of problems in
you either direction it's usually
there's a one dominance pack or there's
or the randomization is just too chaotic
and you don't feel like you understand
what this guy is supposed to be about in
the game world creates that god role
scenario where everybody wants to go
after that one thing yeah and so yep I
mean right now it's gonna be there I'm
actually very curious to see what who
shows up at the top of the list of
played heroes and which ones people
pursue and will iterate through them and
make you know our intent is usually to
you know we want every every hero to be
viable
awesome and so we'll iterate through
that just like any other you know here
obvious game and so we're that's our
that's our thing I always had people
always ask me like like what kind of
feedback and I get I'm like well we have
it we have the hero part system so tell
me about cards that you don't think are
as effective his other ones so we can go
back and we can get through them and
make them popular and make them feel
like they have it they have a place for
those of you who may just be joining us
now I'm here with Darren sug creative
director of fortnight's as always likes
or subscribe to our channel on YouTube
are very helpful to us and let us do
these kinds of things so you'll consider
doing that you know what one thing
that's going on right now on the screen
is that they're doing a Down drone so
drone you know the fortnight uses a
bunch of little cute little robot to do
stuff and drones in the world to ferry
people about and the one of the drones
has gone down and the group has to has
to get together to defend it it's
actually one of these missions that only
spawns when you're in a bigger group and
it's actually one of the more top at the
one of the more difficult encounters for
groups because it's time-based year your
group has to come back together and hold
the line while the while the drone is
being salvaged so there we just saw the
dance move which people have been doing
at the end of every round for the past
two weeks and I have no idea how to do
it on PC can you let the audience now
yeah how do you dance in fortnight yeah
so you can go to the your global chat
and you can type whack dance and that
will that will execute the one of the
dance moves and if you do whack
ride the pony that'll do the other one
so yeah and right and for and and and
controllers it's it's down on the d-pad
and it yeah there he goes he's got it
and then you can execute from from from
the milk picker level as well so yeah
it's been one of our one of our things
like actually you were talking about him
and Mose before that that's sort of like
hey do stuff in globalchek commands is
actually sort of a little bit of the
legacy of the the AMA the older online
game era nice all its cool throwback yep
let's talk about building because I love
building and why people like Billy we
made a building game so yeah that's why
minecraft is no popular um but one of
the interesting things is so you build
by cooking squares so you have a basic
shape you click squares yep and
you manipulate that shape are there any
crazy shapes that people might not know
about um cuz I know I've seen some weird
reverse triangles and people have made
things I don't know how to build yet
yeah actually as we were doing this
before I was watching what a good one to
try out just right now if you would is
take a look at the the stairs this is
one I like to tell everybody about
because it's it can be somewhat
challenging to build why don't you try
to see if you can make the little
wraparound staircase see he just did
that a minute ago yep okay and he can
rotate that around and and so you can
place that in a space a lot of people
are trying to figure out like we have
build puzzle missions on landscape as
secondaries and they're always and they
try it's trying to teach you how to do
stuff but people have questions about
how do I manipulate that little that
little pad on the ground so yeah it's
making different versions of those
stairs so although you know in a pinch
if you're just trying to run straight up
into the air like having a ramp it's
fine but if you if you're trying to
actually build like hey I have a 1 a 1
by 1 grid how do I get up to the top of
it like I'm strapped in a cave like how
does that work you make those wraparound
stairs and then you can just walk your
way up in one in one thing right here if
you're not good at trumping or trying to
get the way through you're not a ninja
with the GG yeah yeah so that's so
that's one of the things that like
that's one of the patterns I think is
the most useful there's a there's a
there's a ton of other ones across ramps
and and you'll see like catwalks and and
once you get up to the top or the top
level you'll see some of our players
begin to build full stone castles and
they have the crenellations at the top
and those are the results of fences that
they have edited down so yeah there's
there's a ton you can do with the
building grid so whenever whenever you
guys are out there playing with the game
and you you enter in that edit mode on a
piece you can you can craft you can
experiment and when it's red it's not a
good pattern and when it's blue it's a
it's a valid pattern so you can you can
experiment and I think over time there's
a couple of there's a couple of empty
pieces and the patterns that we think we
could probably add a few more things to
so yeah that's that that becomes
interesting think early in the game too
I haven't found a use for rooftops yet
where'd that rooftop cone shape what is
that what is that design for well and
well in the long run
room rooves however you decide to put
the roots become important to the game
because there are lobbers and which are
enemies that are basically artillery
that fire into the top of your base so
simply walls with no roofs become a
difficult proposition because they'll
lob over your walls and hit-the hit-the
whatever you're protecting and then
there's also the flingers that actually
pick up creatures and throw them onto
the top of your base and then that means
that creatures will be running around
the inside of your palette inside of
your walls you don't protect it so those
top pieces allow players to sort of like
you can make pyramids with them and
those pyramids allow you can kind of
stand on top of pyramid and you can see
around rather than flat roofs and
there's a there's a bit of a there's
some bit of a trick with with some of
the propane tanks and how they bounce
around and and so that some of the
inclines can can affect that as well can
potentially bounce propane tank back off
of a roof yep can you chain things
together so for example shapes and
bounce pads i saw a player do some
pretty interesting stephane bouncing
zombies off of cliffs oh yeah and one of
the objectives yeah can you like
perpetually bounce on fees between to
bounce pads it's not perpetual largely
due to the way the timing works I want
to eat him for a second it's like we're
we run out on out on the server so
perpetual sometimes can be a little bit
weird because everybody has to know
where the enemies are at all times so
it's a little bit it's a little bit
weird so there's some delays but you can
do a lot of crazy stuff with them which
is like imagine you actually have a
pop-up trap and then and then you put
put a creature into the air and then
you're able to slam that that pop-up
that popped up enemy with another push
trap that'll knock them off the off a
cliff or whatnot so you can double stack
them and mmm one of the one of the
interesting older iterations of the game
is like we had people being d buffed
while they're in the air so actually
when they're in there that take more
damage from from other trap types - this
is one of those things that we are
definitely going to play with in the
coming in the lifetime - for a night of
making some of that way more interesting
so when you build a better mousetrap
there's there's more more cool behaviors
with that and yeah I'm seeing the
players already create like devastating
machines where they where they you know
isolate the creatures and then throw
them onto the ground and force them to
run back up your trap means they're
they're pretty creative bunch are our
players now I'm gonna figure out a build
a zombie cannon at some point yeah
definitely
zombie railgun speaking of guns which
people do love yep games like this I
mean somebody runs by you with a flaming
sniper rifle yep and you want that gun
so tell me about tell me about the gun
game what what what are some of the
higher-level guns that people are
chasing right now and and what are some
of the more creative so so I'll talk
more about like sort of the
classification of the guns and the
actual than the absolute specifics but
we have guns if people always ask like
pay I started the game and like a lot of
the guns are hyper realistic and like
they're they're the they are that you
would expect and see and it's you know
he's got it right now on screen he has
at 9:00 a.m. 60 they need to ammo for
and and and those are the more
traditional like hey I just want to have
that good feeling gun but then as the
game unlocked you start finding whackier
and whackier guns some good examples are
like art we have a basically a Gatling
pistol that consumes a huge amount of
ammunition but is but is ultra deadly
and flinging a bunch of lead at people
we also have laser weapons that that
basically fire hyper fast laser bolts at
which deal energy damage which we'll
talk about a little bit later and and
then also we have laser weapons that
actually bounce as down the hallway so
you'll take it you'll you'll you'll
shoot them and then they'll ricochet
through the through the corridors and
hit multiple creatures at a time so it's
it's just like one of these things where
like we have we have everything from the
beginning ARS to to vendor tech
basically are are you know borderline
you know wacky technology guns at the
same time and then of course we have the
what you'd expect we have grenade
launchers or RPGs as well so there's
some there's some there's some very
interesting guns at the end game that
that begin to really widen the player's
ability kits and one of the other things
about those kits is that all the guns in
the game especially at the high level
start having what we consider
alterations which are additional
properties on them so you asked about
the flaming gun before
that's an alteration it's a fire
alteration and so the front of the game
guns is on fire and the bullets that
they nice he's gonna he's gonna pick
that lot that thing out oh if he could
hit it interesting yeah you can shoot
those out of the air which is what Nick
is trying to do right now I don't know
yeah they're you guess so like the truly
skilled can just like shoot down the the
incoming projectiles before they even
hit your base but anyway sorry about
that so the alterations basically have
enhanced properties everything from
recoil speed to damage types and and
obviously damage types actually do
affect creatures in different ways as
you get farther and farther into the
game you'll begin to run into elemental
versions of the hostile flaming husks
and basically lightning costs that that
have different weaknesses depending on
on what they're doing it and as you'd
expect the fire Hoss deals more damage
to your wooden walls so but if you have
a weapon that is that is basically
water-based its oppositional element you
look a little for more damage to those
type of creatures as well and finding
those properties and making them work on
your guns Azrael is he is like the I
would say the fourth tier of like when
you're super into the game you start
like you start that like sort of
decoding and figuring out what how to
optimize that how do you deal with sort
of the difficulty spike in that case
because I know the elemental mods show
up long before the elemental creature so
who do you know about how long you
expect people to spend in in the first
soon cuz it seems like they're not
bearing that first yeah they're
definitely not in the fur in the first
zone one of the one of the things that
were sort of working through is that you
know we you know we didn't make it up we
we said we're an early access for a
reason and figuring out the right time
to have you in the beginning in stone
wood which is the first area and and
teaching you all the things in that
space and having enough time so we don't
overwhelm the user is it something we're
going to be tinkering with so you don't
you probably won't begin to see any of
that any of those sort of elemental
creatures until you start really getting
into blank rectangle just the second
area and then then they start coming out
and our long game plans are to have
you'll see storm properties where like
there are actually properties on
storms that you're fighting that
actually mutate the the creature types
on work as well so you could run into a
storm that's like this is a firestorm
and every creature that comes out of
this is going to be a flint is gonna be
flaming and so they you have to be
prepared for that
so yeah so you have to have crafted that
good yeah and then you'll have to craft
like okay well we're going into that
you'll be able to know in the zone level
like hey we're gonna go into a fire this
fire storm we better have a couple of
weapons elemental weapons that are gonna
help us against that so actually there's
a good time to talk about this since we
ended that round with victory in a sweet
dance yeah um challenge so actually one
of the biggest challenges that I found
in this game was what you do in between
matches so there's a lot going on there
feels like there's two different there's
the the system when you're fighting and
then there's a system when you're
managing your survivors now to be fair I
think games like state of decay took me
a long time to learn to I took took a
long time that game to realize that you
were not one player you were every
player mm-hmm talk me through there's
just a lot in a lot of systems in the in
the menu in between rounds mhm
what's the what's the main idea behind
all right a moment so sort of at the top
level actually that's a that's a great
example of you know we're sort of within
this genre where you know the player is
is the commander it is the the you know
it is you for all intents and purposes
it is the the player is is basically the
leader of a bunch of stalwart heroes
that that go out and try to save the
world and ultimately they save people so
as we started you know deconstructing
the idea behind it we're like well if if
we want you to have a roster of people
as you've seen on screen there and then
what do you do with all the survivors
that you're rescuing because it's the
thematic the core theme is like hey
people are important in the world and we
want to make them powerful integral to
the way the game works so then that's
how the survivor cards were born and the
survivor cards themselves basically you
slot them in squads just like you do
here if Nick gonna open up real quick
and you'll see all your different squads
this is the AMT squad
EMT is make sense it's a health based
thing it actually just gives your your
hero more health on the boots on the
ground so whenever you play the game
you'll see that little those little
numbers moving it's adding more
fortitude which is the attribute that
increases your health and so the more
powerful the survivors that you invest
in this thing the more health you'll
have fire team alpha is in Offensive
squad the more offensive damage you do
so figuring out you know that basically
the your core attributes are based on
taking care of your those squads of
people and you know in the beginning of
the game all you need to know is slot
people into the into the individual
slots and you'll become more powerful
and you will be fine for for a few hours
but over time you begin to realize like
I need to level all these guys up and
they have they have pattern matches
where like they're more efficient in
certain areas like if you have an actual
doctor putting them with the EMT squad
makes that makes him more efficient and
basically gives your your your your your
hero more more health and more power so
that's that's it that's the system in a
nutshell it's actually awesome I've
already I've already seen some really
awesome gameplay videos tutorial videos
from our community are ready explaining
it with like you know like hey highlight
here this is what it does and they're
doing a great job like sort of
supplementing what you know should be in
the game itself and this is another
piece of of our early access puzzle the
stuff on the top level meta you know we
just haven't been a enough time sort of
refining that and that was a we knew
where we were we were going when we get
out we're like hey you know we're gonna
go out the door and players are going to
be helping each other to figure their
way through this and over time we are
going to make it better and easier for
new people to start but there's this
interesting quandary between when you
have an early access audience the bunch
of people will figure it out and then
they and then because they're they're
hardcore and they're super into the
super end of the game and and their
hunger for wanting new challenges and
new content versus spending time making
tutorial ization and and bring on new
players so we are constantly walking the
line between those two things and it was
an interesting it was an interesting
development whole trade off because the
number one piece of feedback we actually
got about for tonight through all our
stuff oh the next one is treasure in
this upstairs well the number one piece
of feedback we had was hey I don't have
a gaming PC and I really want to play
their game
and so we're like alright well we're
gonna go take fortnight we're gonna
we're gonna put all the team resources
towards bring this out so so players on
on on the consoles couldn't get access
to it and we said we have to redo the UI
and we do a bunch of interfaces but one
of the trade-offs that came we're like
we're not going to be able to rebuild
the full tutorial ization in the
timeframe before that and we kind of
just made that trade-off more like well
you know we're gonna do this we're gonna
tell people hey we're in early access
we're gonna make this part better and
relying upon some of the community
initially to get us there but we are not
done like I we you know internally we're
like this is uh if we are trying to get
to a 100 version of that we are at point
to five of those kind of interfaces so I
expect a significant amount of iteration
both around both like howdy how do you
do things in the game and the UI you and
the user experience itself or the X Xbox
and speaking of survivors so early in
the game you have an intro mission where
you launch a rocket but you walk into a
base with a bunch of survivors who are
physically in the game yeah
was that an earlier build of the game or
is that aspirational to be more like
state of decay with your survive so I'm
hearing in the world so yeah we so we
refer to that internally as our as as as
3d home base which is like how how would
you manifest that in the in the game if
we wanted to and so they aren't that
isn't actually an earlier iteration we
just sort of wanted to give people the
idea like there are survivors on
landscape that Nick and find right now
which is like that's just part of the
thing like these are the people that
you're gonna have to say if the initial
the initial run-through is Ramirez like
it's the story is really the commander
shows up and they are and they're our
force of good in the actual overall
world there's a lot of games that are
more sort of murky and everything else
for tonight isn't that it's basically a
more hopeful game where like what
happens is a bunch of people actually
band together and try to do something
good so the commander starts out very
early on it says like I'm gonna go help
Ramirez and then Ramirez when you go and
help her she's already helping other
people like she's rescuing those those
survivors she's trying to hold the line
in the face of the storm and so
ultimately it just as an opening of like
hey this is one of the central themes of
for tonight which is like help helping
out the people and protecting them
so yeah that's that's sort of the
opening of that so going back around we
talked about how we would manifest that
into the game world but we always knew
that we needed to build a UI interface
first because no matter what happens
even if we had the three a 3d version of
it there's always going to be power
players who just want to move through
the system and like hey I just want to
slot a bunch of stuff and then move on
so it's very there you guys seeing some
of the some of our our wall art but yeah
there are always people that are gonna
want to have an interface so we built we
built the interface first and if we
explored it if we decide to make a boots
on the ground version of that that you
wear you can see that I think we will we
will explore that it's actually really
well we'll see what happens if the
players are like really hungry for that
so currently what's persistent in the
world is your home base you go back and
do home defense waves and water
generator yep watch your base get rekt
which leads me the question of some my
co-workers have asked me this I
generally don't pay too much attention
to what other people around me are doing
outside of the zombie defense way hmm
and then people are sort of there to
work together but how much of the
players in the each instance of this
world are how much of it is them
competing against each other versus
cooperating that's good great question
so a significant amount of the core of
the game is built that if you have any
other players you know around you you
are better off for it so one of the
things that's like that a lot of people
don't realize is that nicks in this case
on screen he's actually being all odd
mented by by the players around him his
power level is actually is is 26 but his
his base power is not that lone he's
actually just because he's in a world
with other people their power or the
power level of everybody of the team is
just is it's just augmented so it's
mathematically you are tougher just for
having other people around so even if
you play the game and you're like hey a
guy isn't like within three feet of me
you are better off for having other
people out there so right away from the
beginning we built that combination and
that's actually one of the interesting
parts of getting the balance right
because
early-game we want you to be able to
play the game by yourself actually for
quite a while but if you start stacking
up with with a pro team with a bunch of
stuff like you quickly become quite
powerful and that's what you know we do
want you to be able to do that but
that's a low-level system the next thing
that we did in the game is to people
don't have to don't have to compete he's
got one of the laser weapons already is
you can share guns freely like there are
no level requirements for picking up and
shooting a gun so if you know your
friend shows up and they have ton of
schematics they can actually manufacture
and craft guns for you and just drop
them on the ground and you can pick them
up and have a good time with them like
it's basically one of the intrinsic
things we wanted to do so like therefore
like you're happy to hang out with a guy
who's tougher than you because they can
they can make stuff for you and and
being generous is good now you're asking
why how does that help me I'm a selfish
player if that was the case well your
scores no matter what activities are
taking place on the game world even if
you're doing stuff like ie do a little
mission on the side one of your friends
doing something else those scores
actually aggregate at the end so they
add up and the XP and your success rate
of the whole group is added off so
everybody has made more powerful by that
so the XP is based on everybody's
activities not your own solo so even
having that guy who's like that doesn't
show up until the actual base defence
happen if he's out there harvesting or
getting stuff he's giving you score and
you are getting more powerful as a
result when you go through the mission
rewards at the end interesting or the
the Outlander who is gonna go find all
the treasure chests on the map yeah yeah
now now that there are some like you
know we we've we've long debated whether
or not we should have instances of every
you know when you find a a treasure
chest on the game map should it be
exposed to every player that's true of
most of the activities like every if you
participate in like husk encampments and
you wipe them out everybody gets a
little present box you see that when you
guys play and we debated about how that
should work with treasure chest right
now the reason why we chose what we did
at least a start is the fact that if we
were to assume that everybody in the
game gets gets a gets a gun or gets a
piece of treasure from those treasure
chests basically means balance wise that
everything is multiplied by four and
overtime if you want to keep that in
balance that means you have to degrade
the amount of
yes because you have to calculate for
well what happens if there are four
people with all this stuff so it was an
interesting challenge and that's why we
landed on this for right now because we
wanted to make the loot the loot that
you get out of the strata just feel
pretty good without having to compete
for the inflationary aspect of life oh
but it puts out four copies for
everybody on the team so there's a bit
of camaraderie slash competition when it
comes to some of the high-level finds on
the map yeah some of those things are
are rewarded for that but ultimately the
the true power is the is the mission and
the XP and the reward you get at the end
of the match because that's really where
all your persistence takes place now
Nick Nick strolling through this right
now if you can you can you look at one
of the walls and just so I can make sure
I say this to everybody so and we're
gonna do a little weak point thing so
one of the cool parts about the game is
we have a weak point system these little
targets that appear on what the things
you're trying to hit and hitting those
weak points literally doubles the speed
at which you're harvesting now you don't
have to I'm just as guilty I you know
I'm drinking my coffee I'm talking my
friend and I'm and we're playing
together and I just let it go and it's
fine but if you're really trying to
optimize your harvesting rate I know
locking onto those things that actually
hitting them doubles the speed of what
you're harvesting so people always
asking like oh it feels like it takes a
long time and then I go back and look at
their videos of what they're doing
online and you're not even aiming you
know it is it makes it faster for those
who want it that little mini game is
there to sort of speed it up when you
want to do it and if you're just feeling
like I'm just want to press some buttons
you don't have to but it is valuable if
you if you engage in it and it's one of
those things we've tried to teach people
through our user experience testing and
we actually added it it didn't use to be
in the skill tree it used to be just a
property that you got from the very
beginning and but what we found out is
that unless we put it in front of you to
buy in that skill tree people didn't
realize they had it or what it did so we
actually added the skill tree so people
have to spend a skill point and they
occasionally will look at the video to
tell it what it does so we tried to
increase its usability but if you want a
pro tip like that for gathering that is
the number one thing I can tell you so
just to be clear it's not always
immediately unlocked for characters
which is why some people might miss it
yeah yeah if you're playing the first
but it is literally within the first two
so you're you know you don't start the
game with it but but quickly you'll
you'll unlock it I gotta say actually I
like that mechanic as somebody who
enjoys building but doesn't like
punching rocks for long periods of time
do we yep absolutely I we have that
conversation we threw out its
development is like what's the right
actually III exactly phrase it that like
punch in rocks and I'm like how long do
we want to do want to punch rocks in
this thing one of the other things you
asked me before about heroes and things
you can do with them it's actually why
we added the expedition system now the
expedition system is just another squad
that you can manage you can send your
heroes out on time missions to bring you
back resources when you can't play and
so they'll just go out and they'll
gather stuff for you and then they they
come back and bring you back loot for
just doing nothing and so one of the
cool parts about it people like we're
talking about like hey I want to get the
right balance of punching rocks to
fighting is that over time people begin
to realize like oh you mean if I send
out a bunch of guys on missions while I
after I long log off and I log back in
they bring you back loot too and so
you'll have resources to start the whole
new gameplay and you may not even have
to you you know punch a bunch of rocks
as a result of it so that's where we
brought like you know so I've got a
couple of friends of mine who also or
like yeah I you know I only can do this
a certain amount of time and I'm like
cool like you just log in collect all
your stuff they can go off and do one or
two missions and then and then they send
their stuff back out and then they're
out they're out against a day and then
obviously people who would love to grind
it's okay it's that it's out there for
you
going back real quick for those of you
just joining us I'm here with Darren sug
creative director of fortnight we are
talking about
I love with guns creative ways to build
things good zombie strategies actually
that'd be a good one to talk about next
if you appreciate what we're doing here
feel free to give us a like subscribe to
our channel so we can do more awesome
korbinite coverage and this game will be
in development for a year before it goes
free-to-play and and it helps us out a
lot so let's talk about addition to
tactics and we're just talking about how
people compete over some of the high
level treasure let's talk about loot
scarcity so how do you get that balance
right cuz it feels like with the
founders pack sometimes I feel like I'm
being grossly rewarded and sometimes I
feel like I cannot get through this way
because I don't have enough bolts to
craft the ammo that I need yeah
how do you handle loot scarcity like
what is the point where a player's
feeling like they're getting enough
stuff out of their efforts they're not
getting like the chatter wydad from
atheon
yeah versus like if you give people too
much then they also get turned off
because it's too easy for them yeah
what's that balance
yeah well that's that's the trick like
so right now like when I think I'll say
about balance is like that that corner
piece he's those are those are copper
ore and they're used to make some of the
more powerful weapons so keep your eyes
out for it for any of the or silver war
and and and they they help but they are
usually hidden away in the spot and in
the corner hang on Nick if you go back
there's also an ammo crates on the
ground in the right-hand corner so or
left-hand corner sorry and basically
they give you a bunch of stuff so it's
number one it's like how do we handle
the balance well well the first thing
we're gonna try to do is make sure that
we're educating people that they know
that these kind of things exist our
number one difference is that initially
when you start playing the game you're a
little you're like there's so much stuff
in the world I don't know what to get
what to search like there's another
crate up there on that shelf and it's
like and and and education is the first
thing of like realizing what comes from
that so so that's the first thing and
it's just basically we've liked the
insider baseball version of it is like
we call its instrumentation
like is the player understand what their
what's going on in the game world and
they have a they have a if questions
about it I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
next gonna show you what I do to
specifically go through these kitchens
you see those nuts and bolts he's gonna
destroy that that that stove also gonna
get rusty mechanical parts and more nuts
and bolts same thing is true destroy
cars destroy it get metal like if you're
looking for four very specific things
some of the real world analogs actually
works out it's like oh I could probably
get nuts and bolts at it by destroying
this fridge because it's like that's
just the thing that holds it together so
when you're looking about the you know
we're wondering about loot scarcity it's
like actually some of the stuff is it
maps to more real world so if you're
like hey I'm out of bullets look around
the world for painters but also if you
want to make your own stuff you learned
that like oh cars are good sources of
nuts and bolts
you know houses and kitchens also have
them and we generally find early-game
when you're experiencing that scarcity
it's our test is generally because you
don't understand like where to go yet
awesome [ __ ] even destroying that toilet
should hook them up we just got bacon
out of it okay I don't think you want to
eat that so yeah you know it's a thing
but yeah after he destroyed it he got
some more nuts and bolts so if you're
looking for those kind of things the
world probably has it in it
it's just question if you know where to
lock and over time we're actually gonna
build a probably an encyclopedia we can
go inside and be like hey let me show it
let me see this this item and where I
can frequently find that again it's just
one of those features we haven't we
haven't fully developed but we're gonna
need it but I guarantee you the internet
right now is making the wiki that's
gonna tell you how to go about get the
most optimal version right spot you know
it should be in the game so that's one
of the first things we do in terms of
handling like food scarcity other thing
to find out too isn't if Nick really
wants wood best thing to do is actually
hit the trees tearing down somebody's
garage door is actually a little less
effective than just going to the raw
materials the same thing is true of
stone giant piles of rocks is way more
efficient than burning down somebody's
brick wall so if you're looking to
optimize like hey loot distribution it's
like go to the raw materials and I just
so happens that the air quotes raw
material for metal in most urban areas
is the cars it's a little weird but hey
they're our thing you know the old days
cars were made out of metal
yeah not plastic so so if you want to
make bullets you go into somebody else's
house and punch their fridge out me but
blow up the refrigerator or break up
their car you heard it here that's where
bullets come from interesting too so
also like the raw resources like trees
and rocks are more give me more than
been breaking down houses and walls yep
nice so I think probably one of the last
things we should talk about is strategy
because I think that's a big part of the
wave defense portion of this game yep so
I feel like beginners always just wall
off the generator and go I'm good and
then they get bad results or like it's
tough
whereas what I'm seeing right now are
the experts they go and they wall off
the spawn and build pathways for the
zombies to walk their traps yep so the
zombies just confirmed the zombies will
like generally follow the path of least
resistance correct within within reason
they will so we're not you know it's
interesting where we are not quite where
where there are tower defense games that
are actually linear they express where
the pathing is we're a bit more dynamic
the creatures are a bit more about by
basically more intelligent than that
well there's smasher in there so those
all see if you can hit nice jobs and
with the airstrike before you came in
hmm
so the the way the the path thing works
is if you create things where where it's
not too much too overwhelming so you
don't want to have a lot of like
switchbacks and all these other things
to go through early on ultimately the
best way to express it
is creating some large paths where you
are kind of guessing where where the
where the creatures are so two or three
some areas opened up so tile areas and
then you build grooves and walls around
that and those kind of wide pass just
tend to work better for a bunch of
players I've watched some outpost
defense and some storm shield defenses
where players if you're just try to
funnel them down to one little nub the
AI don't play like that but if you get
them a little bit why two three areas
you have a much better way of exposing
the trap damage and excuse me and making
areas pets a sometimes the zombies are
just like no
gonna do that yeah they're there they're
just they're not linear paths they try
to calculate a best path and so you're
but you can you can kind of mess with
them a little bit seems like those
little walls are one of the largest
effective defenses when it comes to
shooting the other says our windows just
for show yeah
so it's interesting windows you would
think are a little less good but the
smasher actually will roll through
fences quite easily so they counter your
your your something we used to call
fence town and basically if you just put
fences you can shoot over that's good
but if they're really weak to seeds
units like smashers so Windows on full
walls are not as weak against those
those those seeds units like the Smasher
which is that big purple creature so
it's really about what you want and
you'll quickly it's kind of weird
because initially you know it there are
combinations that seem really effective
but then as the game evolves more
creatures begin to come online and then
you realize like oh like all these
fences don't do anything against the the
Smasher so although I can shoot over
them if I if I'm make an entire base out
of them and I let that Smasher get in
there he can destroy like whole lines
because he'll charge through and destroy
many of them all in a row so it's
important to like sort of work it out
now one of the things I think we're
gonna be messing with a little bit and
Eamonn know it's something that I wanna
i personally been wanting to improve is
the ability to see out of those windows
while you're holding a gun it's a little
bit tricky in third-person so I wanna I
want to basically make that a little bit
easier I noticed in the menus there was
a first-person is it in the Gulf right
now totally is a first person camera
toggle but we put it in there largely as
an experiment a couple of bills to get
actually quite a while ago it's probably
a December of last year and I asked you
know we talked about taking out and I
was like you know what just leave it in
there there's gonna be a bunch of
players that want to play around with it
but that view doesn't have any of the
gun positioning so you
see you're the physical gun you're
holding it's just a cursor and then you
can explore using it and it doesn't work
but it's it's not really fully supported
it's one of those things like many like
many aspects of 49 disorders like we
were experimenting with it I said hey we
can just leave it in there but we didn't
actually it's not a polished experience
so but it's fun to play actually I
played in it and it's kind of fun when
you're exploring a building in
first-person mode you're just looking
around it can be kind of creepy punching
everybody else's fridges yes I don't
know the survivors would appreciate that
listen like you're just you're bringing
them back to the base and shooting
creatures that you know sacrifices have
to be made yeah visual design of this
game so I did notice it's not like it's
interesting I think it seems like the
visual design for the characters are
kind of across the spectrum for
different different ways people dress
yep like action notice a wide range of
body types and what was the philosophy
behind the appeal of the visual design
of the characters so like there's a it's
basically cute prawn world a fortnight
is obviously stylized
and so we wanted to have its you know
it's some really cool quirky looking
people in the game world and you'll see
a lot of them really that are sort of
people designed on the survivors the
average Joes are you know feeling pretty
stylized but but then over time we
decided we really wanted the hero cards
and the heroes themselves to feel a bit
larger than life and feel powerful so we
we took a design pass a while back to
actually make the these heroes big and a
bit larger than life because they are
they are doing heroic things in the game
world and that and that design of is
supposed to be form follows function
with regards to this it's like this is
the case where we're playing as a ninja
here right and she's she's she's got her
she's got her pants on that navel her to
move and and and obviously she's got her
little four little ninja hood that's
down in this version but but you can
still sort of iconically understand what
she is and you'll see her little piece
of like everybody in the world of
fortnight who is a hero it kind of has a
piece of technology that that allows
them to be super awesome in this case
it's the ninja has their little double
jump boots and and you can see that the
little fire coming out of that
and so that's their character design
you'll see although all the unique
heroes out there you'll see their
soldiers with their with their grenades
they're super powerful and they they're
that just sort of the form follows
function of all of them but the overall
style is just was always rooted into
that a little bit of the the you know
larger than life Pixar you know plus
plus the Avengers sort of feeling of
like these guys are heroic and powerful
and awesome
that's Lars going up in the thing he's
the guy who pilots the van clothing
customization uh so two-fold answer
there is that as you evolve heroes you
unlock more accessories on them so as
they get become more powerful like that
motorcycle helmet that dude's wearing is
a result of him achieving his evolution
and and certain heroes also have
backpacks as well that unlock over time
since we use a hero card model the
appearances are bound to the actual the
actual card itself it's like that guy
wears these pants in this hat but I bet
in a long enough line although I don't
know when we want to there's a couple of
other things in front of it
that we may come up with a way for free
for us to transform or collect
appearances of if I unlock that helmet
on this guy by of leveling into a
certain level and maybe putting that
into an inventory and transferring that
to another card it's just more it's just
interestingly the way the model works it
makes it a little more complicated than
you would think but a long game I bet
you will probably come around back
around to that so I think a good way to
end this stream would be to punch some
llamas if we have any blue llamas
because I gotta say that is probably one
of my favorite things to do alright
usually my kids walk by and say new
candy that is that is right yeah so yeah
we we we more or less are you know we
the sort of metaphor we have is you know
we're more or less a card pack game
because we advisory for cards and like
our manifestation of those packs are the
llamas and their llama pinata
specifically not just llamas so before
you before you blow it up if you if you
right-click on that on that bad boy in
the loop in the loot tab go back to
there and just and push down the button
you can make they talk to you they say
different things the llamas have
different personalities they sort of
google thing
and and and so one day the we were like
well we needed to have a like a
container for stuff what did we decide
to do and the the the artist got
together and they made some really cool
like vendor tech looking boxes and
everything and then and then somebody
came back said what if we did pinatas
and we'll make it in the shapeable
lama and actually at that moment
everyone was like are you you know like
some people were both horrified and
amused at the same time and we're like
let's do it let's go all it so we so
this is how that's how the llama was
born I you you okay on this account you
don't have any more you don't have any
more founders things so I yeah I know
you can't yes so yeah so I don't know we
can't open any llamas on this I feel bad
actually develop our credit card
throwdown no I know actually you know
the thing is is like yeah it's an
interesting yeah the thing is is like
I'm playing I'm personally playing on a
standard account too so you were talking
about that earlier it's like hey I get
the rewards that the players get on that
level too so man one day though that
should it be fair though there's a lot
of videos from our from our or from our
community about opening llamas on the
internet so I'm sure if you want to go
look it up for those not playing the
game you do get you do get them through
the course of new normal play but
there's also a transaction system where
you can but yeah bucks
yep the amount of yeah we they are
they're awarded yeah for a game play via
quest versus your via your collection
book that's where you put like duplicate
cards you have and by filling that
collection book up it actually gives you
more stuff that allows you to get more
card packs and then and then there as
you get farther and farther up there are
also missions that also drop VBox and
then on top of that helping other people
this is an early game tip helping other
people with their storm shield defense
automatically gives you many llamas so
helping other people with their bases is
key and it's like and we reward you
quite quite well for doing it so if
you're like wondering like hey how do I
get mini llamas it's like go help other
people you'll see them in global chat
like hey I'm doing another outpost
defense you want to go join that stuff
because we really wanted to incentivize
people to be able to play together so
enjoy them llamas you heard it here yep
that was Darren's
creative director on fortnight's thank
you so much for joining us you guys were
watching this on YouTube so you know if
you guys can like or subscribe to that
channel that's a big help to us um or if
you saw this on GameSpot also just
really appreciate you guys talking to us
in the chat because we take those types
of questions and we talk to developers
and then we can do live streams like
this thank you so much for joining us
and we hope you enjoyed for tonight